- So how do you go
Ah ha!
How do you think?
What happened?
You're rubbing your head.
Oh, no.
Right here is just aching.
It is?
Yeah, I don't know why.
Is it the conversation?
Like my brain is
just so excited.
Your brain is so excited?
Yeah.
I've never met an
astronaut in my life.
Really?
Yeah, have you ever
tried any space food?
Um, no.
What was the strangest thing
that happened to you in space?
Just about everything
is different.
You see things that
you know what they are,
but you haven't seen them
in that perspective before.
But while your space
walking-- which
is your question-- what do you
do if you go to the bathroom?
You wear diapers.
What do you think of that?
Just like when we were babies.
Adults are babies?
Adults are babies now.
Like if you're trying
to fix something,
did you ever let go
of it and it flew off?
What do you think
we could do to try
to prevent the from happening?
Glue your hand to it?
What your favorite
food on earth?
Pizza.
Pizza?
Yeah, that's the
one thing we can't
get in space when I was flying.
But now, for the first time,
you can even eat pizza in space.
How did you
become an astronaut?
Well, you have to apply
to become a astronaut.
Astronaut schools?
And then I had to go
to astronaut school.
And I applied and I got
rejected three times.
Took me 10 years.
When I grow up, I actually
want to be an engineer.
And I heard you're one.
So can you give me some
tip on some things?
Just to keep your
curiosity going about things,
and learn as much as you can.
And it's going to get harder
and harder, so just keep at it.
[music playing]